yo father in the red rocket Shh
[ __ ] Callen it's over Bry you old ass
piece of [ __ ] oh man it's so gonna be
here dude thank you for letting me put
up my art do I like how long does it
take you to make six seconds that's how
good is good though though scribble it
out it looks good you you your turn 18
Rookie of the Year and I'm glad you're
here keep a because we got this little
[Music]
man look at how tight this is oh my god
you earned it man what you earned it I
feel like I said I want to make a little
speech please do dude this is uh this is
for this for all the haters out there
this for everyone that said I couldn't
do it [ __ ] you're wrong I proved you
wrong again and again and again and I'm
gonna keep on proving you wrong and I'm
taking over this podcast that's an
announcement I wanted to make to you
guys good it's no longer the fighter and
the kid okay the kid is dead
the kid is gone it is finally the Red
Rock forever broke thank you so much you
guys thank you so much you earned it
machine hand made this huh god this is
so nice dad told me that tape that after
hours that these guys may make you make
Samsung phones is that you have to make
a day 35 you have to do 35 a day there's
time if there's time
dude this is a this give me interesting
find the kid cuz we got the girls from
call her daddy
shrim barstools coming in every couple
want to die me dimes yeah man I would
say there you would say what kind of
like the love line for the younger crowd
like when you listen to it you're
dropping facts about like dick pics DMS
relationship advice how girls think how
boys should think it's a new revolution
for how young people are we're never
allowed to talk for some for so long I
feel like women had to be restrictive
over when they talked about sexual [ __ ]
and now these girls are showing that you
could say whatever the [ __ ] you want
they remind me of me and Brian if Brian
was 30 years younger like you asked
youth like 20 year olds they old are
these old are they 14
14 about secondary house they're like
during the 2020 yeah they're like 40 46
25 24 most part about being a girl in
Hollywood she'll be they'll be in their
20s for the next 25 years for sure but I
feel like since they're younger cuz I
pretty sure they're 24 26 I'm not gonna
do it because I don't care I know
they're younger but if they were older
you could never bring up their age but
because they're young I feel like it's
not as insulting like if I was a cat how
old are you cuz cat looks young as far
she is young yes I'm 13 yes you see what
I'm saying you guys get him young
meanwhile Chin's a hundred and nineteen
correct but he knows his [ __ ] yeah so
wise you know oh you have such a wise
face do i yeah who me like a man who's
seen the world huh and you have right
and seeing the world in the wind like I
feel like when you get like when he came
out of the womb he saw murder like right
away he came out just with a weathered
face just like he's been through some
[ __ ] yeah
like you're on the front of a boat yeah
right right right right right like
you're just on the bow is it yes Turner
the bow the bow but but you're on the
bow but you're born on the back you're
born in the bow you were born with a
boat that's the boss it's probably
Springsteen s born on the bottles like
you row
now with these two check these two
chicks I checked out some other stuff
and these two chicks and I'll probably
get you no hate for that these two
broads and I checked out some of the
corrections yes sir the it's good it's
it's it's um it's like smart dirty talk
maybe that's the best way to say it's
smart dirty talk love lines smart dirty
talkers love line like that dr. drew
it's dirty talk but it's smart but it's
also it with a doctor yeah no words I
thought they were both doctors there are
the doctors are neither of them neither
them are doctors let's find out well if
they're not they can't come on anymore
call her daddy by the way I was trying
figure out the name of the podcast I'm
gonna ask them all about that call her
daddy call her daddy they're almost the
opposite of the me to movement right or
they kind of they kind of for it because
they're the obviously than me do
movement there come on know the hashtag
come on no you know what's so funny
about that call her daddy is uh it's
double entendre right so it's saying
like call like call me daddy what a guy
would say that to a girl sexually and
then call her daddy like you got to call
her daddy cuz she's up to no [ __ ]
good look at that great photo
Sophia Franklin and Alexandra Cooper
Sophia Alexander I couldn't have more
like perfect names for that there's
Alexandra I'm glad you're here because I
am I didn't want Kalyn to getting me to
movement he would with installed they're
too hot I feel like you know and they're
young and you know him with young girls
he like likes me like Goulding's any
little rat he sees younger I see him
sometimes stand outside Callen stands
out of high schools and when the school
gets out of like 2:00 2:30 whatever he
claws the fence and he just and he
climbs the fence dude it's [ __ ] gross
yeah if you just start talking about
young girls his mouth starts to salivate
yeah you see like his left side group a
little bit and it starts getting when
was like you draw together this this
[ __ ] is huge there [ __ ] is [ __ ] huge
and it's on the way listen to it you can
you can figure out why because I
listened to it and I thought they're
definitely checking all the box
yo now look it up is that shocking just
doing general research that's okay
you're lucky my original host Brian
Collins not here 51 gross no I [ __ ]
you guys we don't want to me to move in
okay okay no
together he's not my type
for gates this is called 2x2 I mean four
days ago Mike who's the block what's
your vlog guys am what's your name Tom
Tom Tom's the best I love that shirt Tom
how long have you been with them gimme
well since the beginning but which is
which is like three weeks six months
yeah you but you were with Barstow
before this yeah
odo how is this is it annoying oh my god
only it's different
no it's different follow our story right
the Marshall dudes yeah Tom goes home
and I didn't cuts himself he said he's
got that like he's got that nervous
tension where he said ya know I like it
dude filled with wine we kind of picked
Tom I keep another toy someone who owns
a person he's happy down there he likes
it in the basements we were always
worried yeah we were like girl enemies
but she loves that she's like listen
sorry haha show she don't you've been
with your girl
get rid of her dude no no I think if she
follows you guys
he's only mean really other dudes right
yeah like you oh my god I'm sure you
have a lot of women audience but in
general the crazies that maybe he'd get
some riffraff from our dudes there's
girls that are like who is recording the
same boy
what's your female-to-male ratio do you
know it started as 50/50 I think it's a
little more women now but I don't know
exactly
this show is ninety-nine point eight
guys Oh beautiful like every show I open
up whether you're whoop it's a real [ __ ]
bros nobody likes the smell of morning
dick I know it's like it's like funny to
say it's because did get sweaty at night
usually naked I know I feel a little
welcome to do yeah so I get scared a
spider something's gonna crawl up where
it shouldn't spiders gonna cry vagina if
you have a vagina would you not be
scared about it spider can crawl on my
dick your dick hole just as likely as
your job we call them we don't know cuz
you're like this like you sleep like
this no spider I'm crawling your vagina
it scared me all furiously making yes
sometimes what are you wearing just my
undies gesture I'm old-school I wear the
whitey tighties stuff okay yo but it
circumcising smell more than normal day
I know you know a lot of uncircumcised
dicks and they don't smell it no what do
you mean they smell good friend of mine
works in the ER and he they had a guy
that came in who was in his 30s and he
was uncircumcised yeah and they were
like he was I call this such such pain
there's such pain such pain and so they
go to check him out and he's looking at
him and he's like I can't really see
what's going on but then he's looking
and he pulls back the sleeve he pulls
back his sleeve and it's like a
doughnuts a mini doughnut size ring of
like Sh magma build-up Oh like never
wash sleep he never cleaned under the
the sleeps it's a wizard sleep you never
had a like surgically take it off and
shouldn't go and the guy was in such
pain he was crying they said he passed
out a few times I would pass out got a
pain your sleeve got it under the sheets
yeah so they can be stinkier than usual
never washes his dick but a normal thank
you extreme case yeah this is the one
this is the guy we're just getting right
into it I also hear sorry
I also heard and I wouldn't know but the
guys who have the hoods it feels better
like sex what's to compare how would
they know that it feels better than what
you wicks what could you cut nerves mmm
did you circumcised later in life we
need to ask them when you stick the head
in when you stick the tip in does it
feel good yeah but yeah that's it you
might be like you're at a nine I'm at a
10
how do you know how would we know I
don't know we don't know we'll never
know that's why I don't think I don't
believe in that I think sex always feels
good so like we'll just say everyone's
experiencing it yeah so with you guys in
bars you're the only ladies at bar still
with your show right no so there's um
one other show they do more of pop
culture you know they have other shows
where women really yeah hmm they're
right hey we're the only extremely
explicit that's why it works for you
guys yeah like when I listen to you guys
I was telling him before he came in it's
almost like a Loveline vibe in though
neither of you are doctors it's almost a
Loveline vibe for the younger audience
yeah yeah you guys are telling it like
it is it's similar to that it's
definitely also interesting to us though
because our demographic we thought that
was gonna be our demo like younger and
college and then people are sending us
in like I just want you know like you
saved my marriage and they're like 40 50
which is really kind of cool it's like a
very wide demo but the interesting thing
to save someone's marriage from a
podcast yeah I agree
their marriage
but that a lot of times that's how
people get their knowledge these days
yeah yeah I get a shitload
by the way they should be careful where
you get your [ __ ] knowledge like I'm
taking nothing from this show from yeah
like we give no worth in life it's like
this but it's not the world you guys are
living it right yeah really unhealthy
advice but it works that's in the way
we're not yes and you know it's not like
you I was listenin look drivin today
like you're in your town how take a
booty pic we're like noon we're like why
your woman's not [ __ ] you and stuff
like that yeah it's good info yeah it's
great envelope but it's almost the anti
relationship podcast where we're moreso
talking about Millennials in 2019
you're not we're not looking for
relationships right now right and so if
you want to go listen to relationship
podcasts for like healthy advice of hey
guys fix your marriage not know you have
an episode called how to finesse a [ __ ]
boy or a [ __ ] yeah that's not
necessarily healthy advice why not
climate like with uh oldest [ __ ] gonna
do this come on
that's a correct climate with the like
tinder and going yeah or dm's like oh
man you know like like with DMS I'm
assuming you're getting you were saying
you get a lot of female deer oh yeah
what I mean we love new oh yeah new it's
girlfriend up there new yeah so we
should see we should see some of those
just yeah this is why this hit home for
me because people think I I do I get a
lot of female nudes but I get a ton of
mail new pics I just get dudes at say
[ __ ] I don't get nudes anymore I usually
lose on snapchat from guys it's a but
now it just guys that say weird [ __ ]
like I want to strap you down
yeah but it's so vulgar it's like dude
it's kind of hot yeah it's really
makes you feel good it's awesome that
you've got so readily why screen shot
then that we have a group chat amongst
all my friends like check out this yeah
those are smarter than that though girls
know if they're gonna send you something
that they're really clever about the way
they do it but guys yeah I think it
depends dude the girls send in nudes for
us to give them feedback and approve it
for them job and did you guys help them
out he like lift up your arm a little
bit and send it away yeah change the
angle bits your house is bigger yeah and
you two became experts I'm sorry that's
how you two became experts always laugh
we're like we're not experts we're just
more so exploiting ourselves and then in
turn people are yeah well we definitely
have an idea you have an idea are you
are you both single yes okay so then
you're in the game right now so you're
playing and what happens when one of you
gets in a relationship then you have to
like change the angles right we actually
signed something where we can't know we
started I thought you guys made that
pact they made a pact yeah saying this
they're not gonna promise for you can't
I get boyfriend's right but you can
because you won't still be doing it and
then it would just it's gonna grow with
you kid we both started I was a fighter
for a long time so the the crowd came
with me through that to retirement
comedy like they're gonna go on the
journey with yeah that's fine because if
one of us does get one it will be it
will be a new experience exactly right
now we're so enjoying single life in New
York and like starting this show it's so
news
would you turn on a [ __ ] same in the
middle of her I'm really interested I
promise thank you guys one of you will
get a boyfriend
nao hide it from the other one you know
you will know she will yep
we're with each other every one vote
Amanda how long and how long have you
been doing this Shona how many weeks
like six months okay I cannot wait to
this living together thing this growth
this like they hate you oh yeah still
get together I can hate you Brian we
know actually talked about that we're
like we're gonna live together for one
more year and then we're probably gonna
get like studios in the same building we
work it would be better content free
right yeah the time right now because
really like we have like guys over and
then like I hear her in her room and we
like make jokes about math so it's like
kind of great so you get out like so
let's say you hear her in a room with
some dude I'm like oh I knew exactly
what you'd like damn girl you're really
going at it
oh yeah it's good content to live
together yeah it is it's really and I
mean that we'll wake up at 3:00 a.m. and
be like all right let's start worrying
were you doing the podcast prior to
barstool no oh yeah yes we do episodes
for yeah the front-end part a really
yeah they've contacted us so hard so you
only did four episodes on your own what
was it called call her daddy daddy
yeah bar it was like yo we're gonna put
you on our black one
tell me about call why why the name it
was actually such a random thing he's
not in a coffee shop for hours like we
need to have a bomb name like I've got
to make sure it's amazing and we
actually refer to a vagina as a voodoo
clam so we were gonna call it the voodoo
clam but then we're like no cuz that's
like guys won't be interested as much
though we go
yeah so then I go home and we were like
stumped and we gave up and then I
actually put on a hoodie that says daddy
on it that I had men's I was like oh are
you daddy and she was like yeah yeah
yeah that's like call me daddy and then
she was like oh my god because I mean
calling me in the bedroom
like you're not her father your uncle
yeah I like that that's better
but I think our whole thing was like we
still want to call guys daddy in the
bedroom but girls can also be savage
about bridegroom and you can like give
the Gluck Gluck and like go on that
guy's hook and ride it like an
equestrian yeah that's right yes for
sure to be mommies though no I see well
if the guy's calling you mommy is a real
[ __ ] I say when I come I say my mat
right when I come right when i shooters
nothing I love that I'm gonna come on a
girl I get mom's dude you know game
different respect it's like guys gonna
dress up as babies and like they're into
that like everyone has you guys into
that kind of [ __ ] no I don't think I'm
talked about that on the show though
we talked about we talked about all of
it I know but what's that what's your
what's your favorite fantasy world to
talk about I mean there's so many we
just recently discovered PNP porn
you got a key fob yeah yeah party and
play it's like you're like before right
they're like hitting the meth pipe and
then they [ __ ] like rabbits because meth
makes you super horny
I need you to [ __ ] me harder oh my god
oh my god [ __ ] dies that you in turns
people ironically people do die from it
because it's they all do math and then
[ __ ] yeah and the crazy thing is what's
it call you what P and B when you watch
them like girls will be laying there
like smoking meth and then they start
buckling on it yeah I guess you could
see their [ __ ] cheekbone it's so hot
so how do you watched it before I've
seen it I've seen I'd well I watch
everything under the Sun favourite to
watch we were just walking I don't like
it it's gross okay yeah it's a hard pass
for me I don't yeah that's one of those
things that used to be a website called
a [ __ ] does anybody remember that way
remember that [ __ ] [ __ ] with shin you
know what it was like it was like it was
like a trauma it was a super subversive
like sex website where it was like the
weirdest [ __ ] you could ever find what
[ __ ] like that it would be like it would
be stuff like um I'm not like punching
[ __ ] it be stuff like that around
anymore it's gone oh it definitely up
bad I think I think you know heard a
puncheon [ __ ] no porn I'm the man of
woman missionary or bro
okay you like a little fun dinner like
the storyline opens up on the bus then
what's the rest of the porno yeah I like
know the fun but punch in for stuff like
that it was filled with that stuff so it
was voyeuristic you want to watch it I
don't want to Kirk off that's how I see
it
we say a lot of times we bring up these
fetishes because we don't judge anyone
everyone has their own fetish early yeah
but at the same time like if if you're
doing it people enjoy it and we're not
saying though that everyone has a
fantasy that doesn't mean they act it
out in real life
I need a daughter Shay yeah I'm into it
but I'm not gonna go my dad can come
daddy outside the bedroom with Mark
Kelly [ __ ]
the step-step-step porn or whatever
stepbrother stepdad yeah like that stuff
no oh you don't like it I thought you
say you did like it the daddy-daughter I
kind of him into but why why the stepped
on yeah but you do keep our bronze
stepmom that's a huge egg who would you
like call me Steph Cori on pornhub goes
okay me sibling porn is massive right oh
yeah absolutely important yeah I've seen
behind not into that but it's all fake
so like I gotta fake everyone it's all
real all of its real that brother except
better stepmom I have five step kids how
do you guys decide what subjects to talk
about you oh my god we are like I'll
wake up in the morning I look at her and
like I'm in the mood to talk about
[ __ ] I you know like a lot of it is
personal experience for sure yeah he
just kind of like it really is we pull
from every oh well one day if something
happened to us that weekend if we want
on a date then someone said something
like we just recently were talking about
we went on a date and everyone always
asks us oh my god dating with this
podcast right is it freaking you out
that like these guys have listened to
all of it and a lot of guys we tell them
not to listen yeah and people are like
there's no way they're not listening and
we said they we absolutely know if
they're listening or not way it always
come down
you can't you count that much insight
into someone's life and you don't
accidentally like say yeah no so we've
had to be troubling for you down the
road
in what way and the sense that like the
more the more that you expose people
that you're going to date with the more
guys are gonna be more tepid or act
differently around you because I know
that they might end up on the phone
absolutely yeah same way that like you
know like any like you know like Howard
Stern talked about that all the time for
years that it was like it was hard
because women with him knew that it was
going to come out on the radio and that
was a troubling thing yeah until they
accept the fact that it's like just get
over it it is what it is totally I think
we always joked to we're like well if
you get a good dick review then you
should be happy to be on the podcast
Landorus [ __ ] you're not gonna say this
guy had a small no no no I mean whatever
we're not naming names I need a good
name make it a win in the nineteen we
have a 20-19 you carry on wait a minute
you're giving props to guys with small
dick totally fine it's true there's
something about a small dick back
talking about stepdads with
yeah we're for small thing no we don't
we say names on the podcast we have
giving guys like a bad dick reviews but
where do you find so you're not going on
dates with dudes who slide in your DMS
they're awfully fans no no no no eating
apps for sure yeah what do you say what
are you saying people do that [ __ ] all
the time
yeah fanner you got successful podcast
all that you don't have you don't think
people with successful podcast gets
their DM slidden
when they go on dates with these guys
what's the difference they're fans they
know the show yeah but but but it's
that's like when I only thought you were
hanging out because you're famous is say
you only [ __ ] hang out with someone
because of a thing that's the thing
they'll like them from that thing
yeah didn't they've meet him and they go
what I'm saying is they're saying they
don't want to date fans or guys that
know the show no no sorry will confirm
um we are we were just saying there are
guys we go on dates with that we usually
if they haven't heard it we say you know
maybe you shouldn't listen but you just
hair yourself and like we cool about it
we're totally gonna like have dates for
the big shorter courses yeah okay what
sexual intercourse but we just say that
most of the time if they haven't we're
like you met we would prefer you don't
listen but if you listen just prepare
yourself that right you're gonna develop
a no there no everyone always says like
there's no way they're not [ __ ]
listening I think there are whoa there
there are men that won't listen
yeah but a lot of people actually the
first people that have been like yeah
yeah what do you mean in fact if I went
it if I went on a date with someone had
a popular podcast like that if it was in
the same scenario I wouldn't want to
[ __ ] hear it okay I guess that hard
because we're is you're in the end
yeah that sucks but on the outside but I
just imagine that you wouldn't want to
hear because you don't I wouldn't want
to know all the other stuff not not not
sell first if it's about me but more
like I don't want to [ __ ] hear your
job stuff like your your work yeah
environment I would want to do it yeah
even though it is a social podcast like
I'm telling you guys my deepest darkest
secrets of like how I give the best blow
job and then it's like the guys
listening and he already has a precursor
to what I'm in the bedroom that's kind
of weird so I agree I think it's nice
and guys are like I'll just see how it
unfolds naturally do your parents
they've heard the show yeah yeah my mom
my dad doesn't really listen he's
actually like in the entertainment
industry so like he gets that he's like
what is it yeah he's a television
producer but for sports
he must go he's I gotta leave my
psychologist so she's like not crazy
it's all right what are your parents
yeah my mom um she's a real estate agent
my dad just like owns a business he
doesn't listen both my mom listens no
she's from Saul I'm baby Utah no Norman
and Amish [ __ ] that's the first question
I always get are you more man well W I
mean I mean my grandparents are Mormon
that downtown Salt Lake City is the
creepiest place it's insane if you're
busted
you walk around and it's so honest and
clean it white and weird it n in this
light power I don't mean white people
but it is all white know what y'all want
you always seriously when you land or
when you land Salt Lake to the wine and
you get off the plane and there's a guy
that's standing there and if you're not
white they take you aside with you in
the train I don't know what they do but
I do see them thought I was Mexican oh
they did and they put me on a train
they're like you're like what no
yeah oh my god they took creepy city I'm
not talking [ __ ] but it's weird family
in Park City and I love it yeah but when
we go to Salt Lake I'm like look at how
[ __ ] weird this is weird so
everyone's wearing garments oh [ __ ]
Pennsylvania's really weird I've toured
the whole [ __ ] it's just so why is
Pennsylvania weird it's just weird
because there's like Amish lands and
there's like challah juice yeah people
it's weird assault big it's just it's a
lot and here's gonna accent you don't
have an accent though no because
Pennsylvania has some of the most Billy
accent Phillies like Hale sent home taxi
you would do a girl doing that accent
[ __ ] a guy like oh yeah you want some
[ __ ] water
Salt Lake doesn't have a night there is
no oh there is like people wouldn't say
Mountain they are like mountain man
yeah no I'm trying to get with some
other every time I go there the only
accent I hear and so like they always go
white is right that's what I say white
is right yeah to each other with a white
is right this is so strange like he's
crazy
no it's it's cool I'm talking a lot of
[ __ ] I like such a good city I'm talking
are you guys from I'm from Denver so I
thought to a solid okay this morning
Sophia and I so we're like living in New
York and we haven't we've been to LA
obviously before but we're not like LA
girl oh my to the breakfast this morning
and we're like no one is like touched
any of the bagels we're like putting
cream cheese on all these we look around
not one look holy [ __ ] they got you
staying where Hollywood some shine
Hollywood like near the one all that's
not you knew what one hotel carbs were
like oh [ __ ] it's very we were getting
shamed like [ __ ] holding are we living
off like $1 pizzas in New York loving
that you know we do that we put our
carbs in LA - just abate East Coasters
then we eat our non-carbon Reluctant
those trash the homeless only cards here
throw them right back at you carbs but I
do hate I will say I [ __ ] love New
York
I'm a Chicago kid I Love New York it's a
great city but I don't like how much New
York people brag about their [ __ ]
bagels it's New York bagels everyone's
like obsessive and they like jackoff
it's just black and Brad rates dense
bread you made round and spread and
everyone pizza like you talk [ __ ] I'll
talk with the pizza I like la cabeza la
competes with Iowa compete no no no it's
just that we have a lot of New York [ __ ]
now okay just so many New York
transplants here great but also by the
way that's the thing about New York you
know there's so many piece of shitty
spots in New York yeah that are like
such [ __ ] that you're like well we
don't even eat that choices I got my
best slice and you're like nah that's
garbage and he knows pizzas over it and
these you know Oh Chicago I went to
three top
totally crust here comes the red rocket
dude
it kind of let me call you Brian now the
red rice dude that's it Brian here's the
problem Oh easy but easy red no people
people hate on the casserole now I'm
looking for two people
first of all dude deep-dish pizza is its
own thing that's a casserole it's a pie
it's a [ __ ] pot right now what I want
no I was gonna ask you guys quickly I'd
this is just random but you said your
audience is 90 something percent men do
you have like about 98% 18 to 36 men oh
okay cool we get yeah we have some
females but it's a it's not no I'm
kidding we're about 60 40 maybe 70/30 ok
cool almond oh that's really similar you
know I think what the girls used to be
guys identify with okay man gender norms
- [ __ ] em all you don't need to know
again this is a lot of this is a lot is
a lot of dudes but yeah there's a lot of
women that listen to this
like I said make 16 I think that women
listen to it because you're engaging and
handsome and sweet and Brian who's
usually here is kind of like an old
decrepit yep you know what an old folks
home the man who's in a wheelchair with
a blanket over his lap
who usually sits in this change yeah I
like blackout while he's talking to his
Brendan's handsome and nice and sweet
and he's smart and so women like that
yeah he's like it no that's what I did
when I watched her YouTube I like fell
asleep when he was talking about this is
so good so when did you guys move to New
York so I moved right after college I
went to Boston University and yeah bu a
congressional yes I there I've been
living there for like two years so not
long about the same yeah did you go to
college - yeah I went to the University
of Utah okay nice so real you they say
the real you Miami yeah out there is
yeah you do know that Miami is the yo
Nana hell you talking about her in
sports right so you don't still know
that Miami is the you know you're older
now - let's say to them it's Utah
oh yeah Amy and definitely know how long
have you guys been living in LA you guys
both live here yes yeah 47 years I came
over on the boat from Ireland okay I've
been here 15 years
14 years Oh eight years now well I'll
say wild like it's sad do you guys like
living to your [ __ ] yeah all right
it's a fine what do you mean getting
hard I'm sorry no I said is dating hard
stepdad II think [ __ ] me everything I'm
saying though um is dating hard in LA
I'm married so I don't know man I'm
engaged so are you guys [ __ ] you guys
keeper your any crazy [ __ ] yeah where's
your ring though see your phone put it
on my card sometimes you're not
yeah oh you can see that you're wearing
necklaces okay what seven-year-old
drilled through your shirt this morning
you have necklaces on your the gay guy
no socks with vans look at this look at
how gay these shows okay these are okay
so you're not are you sure Mary no are
you want to talk about it yeah no one's
gay have a three old son knowing we
couldn't be further from being gay son
yes okay so okay okay okay but you guys
what yes yes you have a ring on no okay
okay
we're engaged you know he wouldn't wear
a ring to engage why would a man wear a
ring when he's in gay why are you
wearing what is the real question a man
doesn't wear a ring no no I literally
just don't like it I got one when we got
married
war and I like I don't know three months
and then I said I'm not gonna wear this
anymore
I'd rather get it's like their coffee
six and then I say two and then every
time I do a live show someone will make
a joke and not all the time but like or
after a drunk girl is like hey what's up
and I'm like now you know whatever and
then they'll go are you really married
no yeah and they'll go why don't you
wear a ring it's like we'll do you want
to call my wife
why do you it I was like why do you care
also I agree if you think that a ring is
gonna stop a guy from [ __ ] oh yeah
not gonna have stop at someone's head on
his kind of you can't
I never liked it I worked out a little
while and I was like I [ __ ] I hate
this [ __ ] yeah
in fact more girls tried to [ __ ] get
on the old red rocket when I had a rank
I am landslide girls want to [ __ ] when
you ever ring but she drains lives
though it's got to be like girls in
their 30s see a guy with a ring and they
go he must say secure and say Sagada
20s is a different than these they go oh
I bet you he's got his [ __ ] together
they want to [ __ ] that I swear I got it
so you'll tell a girl I am married or I
have a girlfriend I think okay so like
what no I agree that girls are just as
sleazy as dudes it's just oh oh yeah it
just dudes are stupid
yeah and different about their sleeves
yeah no sleazes brilliant and like they
are those are more so a little sneaky
[ __ ] if if it's animals in New York
girls are little rats the girls are
little rats across the trainer pigeon
and our pigeons go around rats and this
guy that's right dude that's the Nell
rats with wings that's right and they
just go around pecking at stubborn
dumbly doing it but the rats are in just
don't
yeah girls are just can't catch you no
girls are so shady we actually talked
about I know this may not be as much as
what you guys are doing but like we
talked about how to catch a cheater in
2019 or two or how to how to cheat like
one of the first things I think is the
funniest not funny sorry but it is kind
of funny how people are cheated funny
when you're fun okay Jambi
yeah on your phone you have like the
Notes app if you have an iPhone no
people are cheating through the notes
you can actually talk to people from
your neck you can share notes so like if
you go into your phone and she it's like
the grocery list and it says like tuna
yeah it's code for [ __ ] and she wants
more tuna and the guy is like okay I'll
meet you and I'll whatever yeah and it
looks like her grocery list but she's
sharing its weight on a chair you're no
CIA
we are the CIA wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute all right
no no you can just share notes and it
will show up in your Notes app no it
shows up as a note and you can edit your
notes and they will reflect on their Leo
I can be texting in Sofia's notes and so
her notes stay the same but I'm asking
them so if Sofia's boyfriend looked at
it it looks like she's just typing her
jobs realest on her knows how I was
added and you guys I know we have so
much [ __ ] we have so much intelligent
very yeah this is the this is this is
this generation yeah sneaky peeky stay
yeah dad generation was like no go to a
conference in try to [ __ ] a girl to
Hilton and if it doesn't work this is my
thing yeah notes your dad said that's
[ __ ] the help whatever it is if your
Chi let's say you and I are in a
relationship and you're cheating on me
eventually you would cheat on him by the
warranty uh no no if I can win I
disagree
no I disagree you get there so many
people and [ __ ] and you shoot that [ __ ]
to the gray you take it to the grain to
the guy there's so many people that ask
us okay I actually have a question for
you guys people ask us this so say
you're in like a into like your second
year of a relationship sure and you find
out that they cheated like the first
month and then they never did about it
you're not you're okay with that okay
okay
I agree especially a lot because too old
you so we have way more experience when
it comes through so it's like I don't
know but I saw I know like a we got
those first that like that doesn't mean
is cheating a reason for a breakup
depends okay
depends on same thing was a one time I
go if the girl five if a girl [ __ ] I
give your wife if your wife was like am
going with Jenny and her stepdad to
[ __ ] apart you know she [ __ ] like
some guy randomly and he found out she's
a guy was drunk like Aquaman what's my
relationship with Jenny days just your
girl's best friend do I know Jenny well
not really
is she cute we have carbs at the buffet
[ __ ] Jenny would you break up with
your girl over it no there's such a
diatribe a conversation that has to
happen after the fact of like give me
the details I want to know how this
happened and why this happened and like
is it what if I haven't happen though
yeah but but there's more to there's
more to relationships than that than
like did you [ __ ] him because yeah you
were [ __ ] horny and partying and
doing out of control or did you [ __ ] him
because like you're not one to [ __ ] me
down yeah this isn't happening in it
yeah true
there's so there's so much depth to
likable [ __ ] heroes you cheated on
now it's like why do it would be more
bummed if she sucked his dick so weird
guy so because that's a you gave him
satisfaction you got and you got a
hypothetically nothing even though some
women are like oh I get off on talking
it's like no yeah no you don't and you
have to go back left side you know
because we have a juggler you know
you know music on that's how you know
you're from Utah the pupal loophole yeah
no it's not cheating I believe in that
you it's a barrier and it's not cheating
you can't actually you can use a con
when we do we never use a condom at
least come know and I dunno I'll just
say in general yeah wait a minute wait a
minute you're saying so the pupal
loophole me if use a condom it's like a
barrier and it wasn't raw dog which
means it wasn't you don't well but don't
but doesn't everyone in New York half
the [ __ ] wear a condom that whole
city oh yeah definitely I mean nobody is
using cano because you Connor it doesn't
happen by amount here when you buy them
in LA you have to throw them away right
yeah yeah it sucks but the poop hole
loophole yeah bears are you guys into
anal is that why this came up no that's
actually just like one way to you can
get around cheating yeah but do you both
do anal well we talked about on the
podcast tell me right now we'll say we
have some very interests I'm here right
now right what I'm not gonna say that
because we haven't even done our anal
episode so you don't break the news on
that week yeah he'd have been like
asking us out like we have our stories
we have all the [ __ ] we want to break we
do talk about on an episode condom poker
and there are certain Chinese girls that
you have condoms poker like you're like
putting like chairs in like you're right
it all for raw sex and then there are
some girls you know like I cannot [ __ ]
around without it so that I think you
wantem how to tell like if I you're like
I gotta wrap it up with this one
yeah he got yeah you're like you condom
so we all we've got with a lot of guys
like you got a little signs not nobody
no hot enough if they're definitely got
something
yeah no we were just I was just saying
like we give guys a lot of insight into
like [ __ ] that girls we're trying to
give guys insight that like they don't
talk about with
boys correct and that's why I think your
shows something embarrassing okay it's
not even embarrassing but like I'm not
gonna be an [ __ ] but there are so
many guys that go into fingering a girl
like the holy Jack they're still doing
this for Jack hammer fan they're not
gonna behave guy like Kevin finger well
that's also an issue no not choose Mike
you know do foreplay I'll do in my face
I think you should gotta do fingers and
many there's no the big difference
between 20s and 30s okay all right you
don't finger in your 30s
okay you know how to do it yes I am
awake you with your time you [ __ ] eat
that [ __ ] in that no and let me tell
you want again you want to get it
started you want to start the bike you
gotta you gotta tickle the [ __ ] click
okay yeah you want to get the [ __ ] wet
you rub the clip really soft when you
make out yeah I was I thought you were
saying in no way you're like going like
this and you're eating reality no I'm
saying like you at some point are you
still using your yeah but it's like
touching you gotta be collecting I've
got a craigory to finish shoving fingers
in there the jack you know I don't even
like that Aegina hurt yes like no
manners you know what though there's
some like just I know that some girls
while giving a [ __ ] with the fingers
and jackhammer your [ __ ] like do you
like that why not much like when they
lick your [ __ ] you said it in a way
that I don't know that's not true like
an they shove it up no like a little
tickle in they're not even sweating
finger in the ass can be great for a guy
but you can't [ __ ] really I don't I
want to dabble or just on the outside
do you like weird like pressure on the
outside like a little bit of leakage on
the out okay no are you lying
I know do you mean yes you can't and yo
near my [ __ ] discussion why because
it's a no-fly zone this urea py zone you
can't go there is a line across guys
like that so I I find that there are
some guys that like love it and like
yeah you the finger and the eating and
then there's some guys they're like
Ghana or some guys like it and they're
trying to repress it gotta let your
lucky game belching like so many guys I
think it's like Oh anal sex equates to
being gay know if it feels good there's
no sexuality attached to it if you want
it if you feels good in your ass we
talked about it there's like you guys
they like to get pegged yeah fine pay
you can it's not for getting [ __ ] your
girl you'd be surprised yeah
define pay I'll put this strap-on on and
I can you're out no no no no with like a
finger and some like ass eating yeah I'm
definitely okay and you can't okay
that's fine look I say this you have a
women have pretty mouths okay it doesn't
need to go where I poop well your do
don't poop okay I know your poop just
disappears God never happened and our
buttholes are exponentially dirtier than
yours regardless because we have hair
even if we just got on the shower or
into my body versus you out that she'd
be doing that
why do you yeah why do I want to kiss
her mouth is respectful do have Wi-Fi
but I think it's kind of nice and a
girl's won't ask you is it yeah no but
it but nasty is like nasty is like let's
do dirty [ __ ] like what's dirty very the
leakage just like a finger near I mean
ya know you don't want any pressure now
it's dirty to you I
Tom in a stepdad
it's the roleplay of thinking he's
[ __ ] a stepmom that's what he likes
how we're on the same page
hey guys no no I don't have a stepmom
okay um what's dirty to you I'm just
saying like dirty raw uninhibited set
usually it's me doing dirty stuff
usually it's me like you you like
sucking your day which it doesn't really
it can't get that dirty how dirty
I don't consider that dirty that's just
okay Wow dirty Oh like like oh my god
bronzer like like um I don't know what
to do I mean I don't know there's no
BUTT STUFF just just no butts up for me
because I've tribe tried it I played
with my own [ __ ] when I jerk off okay
I have in the past okay but I got over I
tried it a few times like you come
harder no no oh no no this makes me come
harder roll with that when I'm thinking
about something that really makes you
okay what if I edge if I edge I come so
[ __ ] what you're edging while you're
what is it edging means like you get
right close to coming and you either
stop for a second okay or you or you
chill it out so you get right to the
point of ejaculation and use chill yeah
and then you either do something else
with the partner do something oh hey I'm
gonna come back to a like what I go
clean up the house come back with my
[ __ ] throbbing no you go you go right to
the edging is awesome people don't know
about edging is incredible you come so
much harder after you edge cuz you get
right to the bone ejaculation yeah and
then you stop and you switch positions
are switched so your mind turns off for
a second for a minutes rearing your back
bro then when you do how so what I mean
it's gone you're out flat break a bad
break your [ __ ] back every well break
your back I'm sorry I'll come out of
your eyeballs like tears have come yeah
I guess that makes you agree also what I
was saying with like guys can get maybe
you cuz you're older and you're saying
you're like more experienced but there
are guys especially in college that are
extremely uncomfortable asking their guy
friend like hey how do i finger girl and
when you watch porn you don't really
know what they're doing so yeah we're
like I like this is what I like done to
my [ __ ] and my vagina and the porn is
made for guys for the right nations
right so we teach guys like what the
couch gobbler combo is and that's like a
way to eat out a girl's vagina and used
to go listen to that I ever like hummed
when you were going down on your way
yeah yeah I mean I
credible boys toys food food hmm and do
you say like st. hell yeah we actually
had like a lot of guys that said they
tried that technique and they were like
holy Sh a like my girl was like obsessed
and I'll show ya down on her all the
time because a lot of guys go down and
they're like oh my god I'm sorry there
are men in their 30s who do not know how
to eat oh there's girls in their 30s
that don't know what the [ __ ] I'm sure
that's not really guys I don't get
enough credit for for trying to bury
their face in a vagina because it's it's
a skill no it's just like a blow job as
a skill and I would argue most girls are
bad at blow jobs we are great that's why
we worry about all the time we're like
there's it's sometimes if you're good at
blow jobs you see guys reactions to like
what I would consider almost like at a
lower grade blow job I would give and
guys freak the [ __ ] out cuz girls are
giving Charles don't know like there's a
treasure-trove job it's the accessories
she brings an accessories we talked
about it clapping it's brilliant cuz we
always say guys like wow what if my dick
is small and she can't do the double
hand yeah you just do to do this minor
thing and then the bigger it anymore so
you can always feel big was really
you're just trying to tell
I'm glad we're talking about all this
stuff because today is brought to you by
Children's Hospital is double
penetration and a Happy New Year DP'd
before um we talked about on the podcast
we talked about cuckolding yeah are you
into that oh yeah I was well oh is that
where you watch your girl get [ __ ] by
somebody else yeah are you a good girl
watch it you're gonna come in no way I'm
so common it's common its beta matter
you'll never have you beta men like I
talked about it one of the
impracticability shooting it into it
whoo oh yeah that show we we haven't
we're waiting to buy now so I've had my
so when I do stand up why do the mean
grades huh can people come up to me and
they ask me all the time if I'll [ __ ]
their girl oh wait and so would you do
it kind of fun [ __ ] yeah why not I mean
if I was a guide like okay I do I do it
but uh chant the whole time you should
be a Go Go Go yelling ow for advice oh
yeah I wanted to clap I brought them do
it creepy like be in the closet where I
can't see them together like that wants
to offer up that's weird have you guys
ever DP'd a girl together together we
defeat a guy I don't think that's DP I
think DP it needs to go and vagina
vagina and ass and then if you enjoy
widget units in the mouth I've never got
three guys no yeah never I've never done
that good you know a bummer I you know
I know you're not living brother um have
you been you DP'd yeah so trim you uh
the other day I've always thought about
that can you feel their dip I don't know
Jim she needs help he's so chintz 41 one
okay single hold on ladies hot single
eyes okay money good job guy nice guy
hot dude
well nice guy big he's a babe he's big
he's [ __ ] he needs help get a girl
okay I wish you could come to New York
because I la scene I feel like is I
don't even know fish like no that's in
your yeah you should see I'm there in
May we would get your girlfriend within
three days literally or at least a good
fun super yo for the sake of the show
fly him the [ __ ] out yeah for this I'm
there may 13 to 16 times gonna shoot the
whole thing yeah I'll be [ __ ] yeah well
we just got him like yeah I'm down we
did have a segment called chinder we're
gonna sign him up for tinder and then
we'd swipe you know left or right I come
from it go [ __ ] picky McGee over here
where elbows are 2.9 swipes and I
thought that's okay though right
actually some guys don't but yeah well
when it comes a [ __ ] okay not really
it's actually exactly some guy calls
want to crush some guys have like types
for [ __ ] and then like tiny for wifey
yeah yeah like looks-wise hots hot to
Mallik your what ethnicity are I don't
think I've ever dated a girl that ever
looked like the last girl ever
I think any girl little island I mean
III so I slanted almost my whole life
towards brunettes okay dark hair because
as a redheaded personally I can't have
like is that me oh my god is that it was
like kind of Sharia yeah and like what
style do you guys go for single both you
I kind of am into like the dark dark
hair yeah for sure but
I don't really I don't really write but
they want to look like siblings and I
was a little scared if you're both
blonde you look how the guys are blonde
anyway well mine was definitely blonde
and he had like a good man bun and I was
like we kind of look like the man but
yeah shame me on buns are hot they are a
man boy a boy who has a ponytail boy
yeah cuz I men don't do it it should be
called boy bun oh yeah boy little boy
only a little boy with tires no [ __ ]
what is your mo I'll call you out you
[ __ ] boy you boy tie your hair emails
yes yeah like I usually either lean
towards blonde or brunette or guys don't
really give a [ __ ] i hot to meet hot
yeah okay um let's a bit also we're
older so as I get older just be hot and
smart you said I could deal with dumb
chicks oh no does he get older if you're
not like I'd be cool right like you
can't bring her to a business meeting
and she's they go to dinner discuss some
important issue I'm alright or if you
don't handle your [ __ ] if you can't
handle like having some liquor in front
of strangers handle parties on your own
like yeah that's way more important to
me as if you're if you can be left in a
room without me yeah you don't [ __ ]
embarrass yourself yeah it's not even
about embarrassing me it's more about
like can you hold your [ __ ] buddy yeah
absolutely all like girls who aren't
into fashion like they don't dress well
it drives me nuts
oh she's she's very into fat oh my god
you dressed like homeless people but no
you guys look good today you don't just
like this kind of homeless for a
homeless no Layla solitary alia where's
know if you this is a prompt people come
to LA they go to like West Hollywood
like LA so weird that's not LA that's
[ __ ] that's like going to New York go
to Times Square
it's
that's not many of you guys got to go to
watts we gotta take you to calm I'll
stroll around there I think we can over
and get before so what do you guys are
doing PR just for the podcast where he
gets here um couple shows you have some
other shows we go to other shows we are
going on Nick vile vile vile and then
we're going Paul mi hell no but look
back I haven't met him like in person
before Logan Paul good dude yeah yeah
the bachelor mean him live close yeah
okay cool yeah he seems like I mean I
know he's controversial but so are we so
we're like ignited I think it's gonna be
a dome it's yeah it's gonna be a home
run you know you guys in him will be
good to you controversial wise oh why do
you like me daddy Logan Paul why is he
wearing a baby just see that's what he
did like he just talk [ __ ] and like hate
oh yeah
the Japanese thing was the only thing I
remember that we yeah there's that he
said some stuff about he's going gay for
the month of March yeah we just told
them we were gay at the beginning of
this yeah you guys yeah but he was like
making a whole slogan like day from our
Shave November he's like Kmart what's
wrong with that if it's hilarious but
it's not funny that's what he said but
the gay cream is like no you don't get
to pick in June oh really
these are the same people that say that
then everyone can be any sex they want
all the time right the same people are
like there's people that don't have a
title to what their sex is there's no
it's not my campaign yeah yes and like
[ __ ] I'll be a burger I don't like
what these people do that like we can do
a thing but you can't do a thing it's
like why so you did like like gay for
Janice um choose a month amazing we see
fans be like oh my god like don't go on
people's shows like and it's like well
who told you that there's just like
people that right yeah obviously if they
like hey we're very confident we'll make
a perfect but if you're a good content
to be controversial as long you're
talking about it you're good right when
you when is even no one's talking about
it you're [ __ ] right yeah yeah so yeah
we're excited we're really excited we're
happy that you guys have it
yeah we're people he's gonna be in LA
for we're leaving Thursday that'll be
fun get out of [ __ ] get out of here
Oh calm are you gonna go to the west
side go to the beach we might go to
Venice today's give me hottest [ __ ] go
to Venice Beach okay [ __ ] out of the
sunset sunset so maybe I'll see you guys
when I'm in New York yeah how come you
guys have guests on your show we have it
yeah we were trying to do like that now
don't have a show where we don't do
guess yeah I do guys don't have you
don't know don't don't start it and tell
the boys from Barstow what's up I'll see
you in the office in ma'am there never
went on guys good luck with everything
thanks guys Thanks wow that was fun
Rachel yeah Oh are we good good oh good
she goes are we good you know ain't good
dude how about to call her daddy uh dude
I guess she's gonna have to go to New
York I'm willing to buy that ticket for
you to get you a carrier Andrew I'm
serious [ __ ] I'm gonna fly you out there
and you know what's gonna happen nothing
you know why I had that negative
attitude no no it's not negative you
know why cuz he's in dudes you're not
into dudes we don't know what he's into
I know what he's into no wise into cool
dope chicks and he's trying to find the
right one that's this guy he's amazing
listen he's just he's picky picky
definitely key picky or do you one yeah
you gotta be I mean he's been a virgin
for 40 why that's like going to a pound
gone no these are show dogs right he's
been pound no he looks at fret he ones
he's been pound what's a purebred he's
not he's not shopping him he's like we
had a rescue he's getting a [ __ ] pure
but now he needs a rescue though you
probably need a rescue to start what you
probably don't write yourself a little
eat a mutt
yeah you need to get a [ __ ] doesn't need
a three-legged mutt to start but I never
get to purebred I woulda less she that
start yes I'm not adopted you got to
start it up rev the engine bro I would
love to I would love to see you
go to New York and get sucked off ah
please do I bail all those girls ask you
out and you would just get asked just
because he'd go out with them that's
what I'm saying I agree
you go to one bar with them I swear to
god you'll have people swarming all over
you yeah I thought those girls were fun
give me a little bit chaos
where's everyone talking over each other
there
they're the they're the dating
millennial experts yeah man did they
make you feel old at all a little bit
yeah also you kept saying it how old you
are you kept saying well we're older
than you well we're older than you I
mean it was being arraigned in their
head yeah I know they're gonna say on
the next podcast like no we were do
these old guys podcast thank god I think
I can was [ __ ] here they would have
Anna she's embraced does he hand people
moth balls when they leave as that
partisan sometimes yeah mothers
originals they get those were theirs
were that's whether he like a bow
people don't know this but Brian he
takes his dentures right before he gets
in here he soaks him before he gets in
here because he wants him to shine white
when he's on camera anyway I love the
shitty answer we've never had it I love
we never I don't think we've ever done a
podcast like we had I'll say Karen the
porno star before your ear chin and you
can't you know that Fox but she she's a
curveball because a porno star be
incredibly sexy yes see very smart
articulate so she didn't really talk
about porn home like well that's good
no she has some other [ __ ] to talk about
yeah I imagine the the barstool girls uh
are gonna only have to come into
conversation about sex stuff but at some
point they're gonna want to switch it up
a little bit you think that's some right
at some point at some point they get
older maybe I don't know maybe maybe
they'll never forget old la but the I
bet they'll have a show though
eventually where they're gonna have to
censor it a tad that's my prediction I
don't think so
good do you want a show I'm saying if
they want fighter in the kid to be a
show and you have to change the content
level you wouldn't do it you can't do
find the kid as a show you do King as
thing is show you do fine kid as like
you could do fighter in the red rocket
as a show because it's it would be a
good excited you minister correct that
of a one-sided [ __ ] thing when you
sit here and you know carry the weight
of the show putting you have nice traps
you do firing the kid like fine kid 3d
3d which was like a comedy skit show fun
yeah but we can do like the final kid
you can do as a show it'd be boring no
yeah well no it wouldn't be boring you
know it just decide it's not for TV it's
not but they want
podcasts aren't for TV that's [ __ ]
your boy on HBO who the master of the
ringer Simmons bill Simmons oh oh yeah
he was like oh this works in podcast
I'll make it TV show H
many of all these millions of followers
and listeners let's do it and then it
was awful
because a lot of times podcast isn't
translate to TV it doesn't switch over
for some well no there is a reason for
it's just because it doesn't work it's a
different medium different medium yeah
there's nothing new
well no we'll see what happens with that
I I think it's interesting I am gonna
give a better listen to their [ __ ]
because I've listened to it a few times
but it's hard because I'm certainly not
the demographic there's no mid 30s male
that this is like I mean maybe I'm
singing if I think it's really game
they're great those to do me when I say
if if I must have a podcast if I'm not
learning some I'm not listening I'm
entertained for my friends when I'm not
listening to what's your favorite
podcast don't do that
I like armchair expert would - okay drop
some knowledge or an election obviously
rogue in brilliant idiots
there's one called this is not must
remember this do you know yes you must
remember this that's really good they
have a great one on man thin and other
[ __ ] yeah there's there's how it's made
cowards made TED Talks obviously yeah
they can get old though TED Talks for me
for some reason here little boring I
find myself not retaining the
information cuz I'm so bored sometimes I
finish it and I go what what what did I
listen me to I'm like well that was just
her terrible but then my brain will
somehow pick up something and then I'll
go oh [ __ ] you know what that's a thing
yeah I know cuz it's just in your head
you listen to when you run no I no not
really not anymore no I like working out
and listen to it really yeah yeah but
because it's a way to just touch this
time kill and I just don't think about
have to listen to some fight stuff like
Alice and Luke Thomas or MMA or MMA beat
when I'm working out just to maybe I'll
pick up something that might help me
what before I do my fight shows but yeah
but otherwise now music would you run
yesterday the other day you put online
you hiked seven miles some ranth of
mouth yeah yeah so most Doug are you
pretty good not bad I ran seven
yesterday you ran seven we're at
Hollywood baby you're Anna Harland yeah
you put in some miles trying get
stretched city alright I just want to do
it you just feel like do it I just wanna
get it I wanna get the [ __ ] at the house
but somebody's like why you run I'm like
decided to get it just get I get away
for a while yeah I like do yeah me too I
like doing it just cause some of the my
best [ __ ] might be run bombs out yeah
yeah me too and then I have to run and I
have to pin them and then tell myself a
message mm-hmm so I can remember cuz
sometimes I'll be like oh that's kind of
fun or funny and
it'll be gone by the time I get home so
I have this I have to Siri tell my
sister I sent myself text mess I just
started all wake up in the middle of
night and I have to write it down
cuz I'll wake them in a night for like a
bit of some oh my god that's funny
I'll write that down a morn fall asleep
then you wake up gone forever yeah you
have to as soon as a very close if I'm
with my Indian I think some I write it
down like I better write it down right
now kid your kid will give you a lot of
material to a ton let done like I mean
jokes though like your hopes yeah
yes honestly that's what I get my hours
from my three-year-old let's do some
current events yeah baby all riled your
podcast going dude it's good man listen
to whisky listen to the whiskey ginger
you got to come on your say you are
gonna come on I'm gonna come on dude we
just got to prep the studio for you I'm
moving right now so we're gonna shift
shift spots we're at right now in
Hollywood and we're gonna shift it out
of my house you doing out of your house
yeah I want to do it I like driving and
does I want people to feel comfortable
in my house I also want to be able to
like have a drink with them sit by the
pool get comfortable and then do the
show and let them drive drunk yeah I
don't know what yeah I'll get him an
uber yeah I'll get him I'll get him a uh
I get him much Kalen drink whisky with
you when he was on he didn't come yet
sorry I forgot it was such a shitty yeah
he did drink whiskey a little I think he
had a little he's not big whiskey guy in
general yeah no I like whiskey you know
I can only drink during shows see this
white glass days are do one shot and I
go I'm people don't people that come on
the show usually have just a little bit
they go I'm not really big drinker and I
said no no you don't have to and always
always they end up finishing it and then
sometimes they're like yeah what kind of
whiskey are you serving dude everything
under the Sun ice which probably every
week I try to get your whiskey sponsor I
know I'm trying but the problem is
they're so big I don't know if they want
to [ __ ] with me mmm cuz think about that
they have so much corporate investment
that they're like there is one called -
Ginger's whiskey what are we doing - no
but but um make you three but I do every
week I do something else like I do
Bourbons and whiskey's and uh no scotch
bourbon bourbon whiskey no yeah there's
two gingers right there then you sponsor
me Irish whiskey bro but I do like
whistle
I did Joseph Magnus last week I did knob
I keep switching it up as much as I can
are you having fun doing it dude I'm
having a great [ __ ] time the only
problem is I want some more I want some
more
I want someone else and forth I want
someone else on there with me who
produces it me well there's your problem
get a real producer like gone below the
belt just me but Chin's in the room and
this other kid damn and I can finish
stretched too thin I can't I can't what
I'm not saying no chin find me another
change of dance from guys who think
their chin now so good luck with that
there's gonna be guys that legally
changed our name to chin this week just
because they're like look I'm a chin
dude I'm chin chin I'm double chin like
this is your mic from Omaha do you have
again now you have a double chin I'm
chin now all right let me see what's up
on this current [ __ ] yeah let's do some
currents so Michael Jackson's estate
actually found something a big issue
with the documentary in that James safe
Chuck said that his sexual relationship
with Michael Jackson started between
1988 and 1992 in the room where the
train was mmm but the estate released
information that the construction of the
room where the train station is was
didn't start until 1993 and completed in
1994 and so there's an issue which one
is you safe Chuck is the one neither the
user not the dancer the other guy who
just looks traumatized in the eyes got
it leaving Neverland
you mean the lie that isn't even leaving
Neverland the lie the falsified
documentary you think phony phony phony
you don't think you touch those kids
money grab no I agree money grab you
don't think he touched any kids let me
say this I will say this I think those
were out for there is an entire internet
conspiracy right now breaking now
there's a British guy who does a YouTube
videos is the primary thing down about
how fake and [ __ ] up half of the [ __ ]
is the UK version of the documentary
half of the [ __ ] is left out you can go
look all the [ __ ] up of defending
Michael Jackson half of the [ __ ] is left
out well the guy who did it purposely
didn't want any of any other people's
opinions so it could paint this picture
well of course that's what a documentary
is right Michael Moore does
documentaries that are like
super liberal with a liberal point
making a murder you know they left out a
time so where you go oh he clearly did
it like this this in the West content a
things where has happened you know it's
like the state of Wisconsin is like no
dude he clearly did it what's wrong with
you people you know it's I mean this are
you [ __ ] me not only did he do it
though that whole family knows about it
that's my whole thing but let me get
back to this rogue let's do but the
Michael Jackson thing first of all
you're a fan yeah you think I'm a just
because he [ __ ] a kid you think I'm
not gonna stop playing thriller off the
wall is one of my favorites no I do
think I do think he had weird
he had weird pretenses with kids and
like had we I think he had weird [ __ ]
right but but I do think the details of
a lot of this stuff is weird and strange
I mean the how he had a master's there's
a lot of years that like he so he
controlled he bought all his masters and
the Beatles yeah and once he had that
much power then that all this stuff
started to get leaked out so a lot of
people like dude this is [ __ ] Sony and
those I wonder the own power I wonder
what he really did anything I mean
listen those kids stories are like
really identical he loved nipples
there's too many he loved nipple my
promise there's too many to know what
kids that came out like out of know I
didn't really know there is that these
are the only two that have really no no
sir no dude there isn't anymore you can
look it up just two kids these are the
only two how there was a chair there was
Google how many how many accusations how
many children would you say tchau how
many child accused of sexual assault are
there that's how the longest phrase of
all time but like look with Bill Cosby
dude how many were there fifty plus they
all came out yeah so you know it was
real with this it was like you think
only two kids click on that there's way
more than two no but I'm telling you how
many accusers there how many what does
it say the exact figure out how many
turnovers you've been abused by Jax's on
no unknown of course hold hold on
however at least six have come forward
when they were boys keeps going down
I like how they how they go one could
describe his dick quiet be pretty easy
to the black dick I think that works
yeah distinctive marks on his penis
that's so funny by the way I don't even
know he's silly penis he did settle for
23 million deaf families you got to get
a let it go yeah
agree look up scroll up chin right there
during the investigation of Chandler's
claims police questioned around 30
children and their parents yep
all said Jackson did nothing wrong there
you go I don't know man
here's my thing here's my thing here's
my thing I also have a problem the
documentary defaming him after his death
because no one can if he can't defend
himself now that he's dead
yeah it is strange so whether or not
this is true right whether or not sexual
abuse on whether he did sexually abused
these kids which by the way nothing
bothers me more than touching kids I
think it's [ __ ] I think you should
[ __ ] be set on fire and nothing we're
touching a child that's just how I feel
but I don't know how many of these
things are inflated fabricated
hyperbolized did he sleep in bed with
these kids that's probably a fact and
he's he a [ __ ] weirdo and are these
parents pieces of [ __ ] dude these
parents are the documentary acting like
they're exempt they smile sometimes and
they tell me you know the one kid
doesn't talk to his mom he's like where
the [ __ ] you sold him up the rip she
sold his [ __ ] up the river I was like
literally go to Michael's house go to
Michael's house yeah they had in one of
these videos they show another interview
on the Internet of of one of Michael's
whatever somebody that worked for the
Jacksons that was saying that mom the
dancer mom the family that moved here
for him they would call him every day
correct every day begging no I I think
that what the son come Oh he also
married Britney or was dating Britney
Spears and then before this document
documentary came out wait wait Rob Rob
Rob he tried going to the family good
hey I know you're doing the thing in
Vegas let me be the dance instructor for
that and they're like no we're good man
and then went all [ __ ] time soon you
guys also that made who came out like
why would she come out she has nothing
gained from it she tried soon um and
blackmailing before right it's all like
Tess I'm saying the human body of water
here imagine if Michael Jackson really
never did section less kids and just his
name is so tarnished and nobody here but
he was the problem with that time period
right like when all this stuff happens
around the nighties
yeah I'm saying the time period is the
media would not have lent him a hand to
help so nowadays right if something
happened you would do everything you
could in these public mediums like
podcasts shows and people that you know
to clear your name an example is like
Noor McDonald made some off-color jokes
and [ __ ] Netflix got mad so he had to
go on
Yeah right back then I just feel like it
was way less likely that you could speak
up for your own voice and say because
there was only one medium which is
immediate and it was so small it barely
exists and no one really paid attention
and it was red but they said it so
nowadays I feel like someone like
Michael could say the right thing and
clear it up because look at look at
Harvey Weinstein he didn't go on
anything to talk about it cuz he's a
[ __ ] rapist Bill Cosby he's a [ __ ]
rape but this this way drops and also
like if you thought so he said I I was
so distraught I had anxiety attack from
it well his therapist came out went well
no his anxiety attack happened because
he wasn't getting work he didn't have
money he thought he was gonna go broke
right dude there's a paper trail with
all the stuff that lead that it's just
really strange that's all on the fence
but did it happen maybe I don't know I
do think the documentary is so slanted
and so gross the way that this document
and this was another thing they talked
about in this this YouTube video I got a
look at I got to show you what it is but
he basically says the documentary
filmmakers footage was released where
they make them tell the stories over and
over and over so they he's like he's um
what are they called you know he's like
he's like pushing him he's 14 yeah he's
like it so so and then anything with was
it was it with anal play and tell us
more about the info so he was like
leading them leading them leading they
were just living here but as a good
director I know but it's just a problem
it's disgusting that's disgusting for
someone to have to like Jesus is mine
about trash I can't believe you can do
this and release it into the world
without any sufficient a factor I know
but it's defamation of character how is
it not that much yeah his family there
nobody estate control though they are
suing HBO
I know but that'll take this will be for
it's already done but if I'm if I'm
granted were timeout if I'm HBO I don't
put the Sun in here no they do because
now people are you know I'd go do you
have you have evidence no we can't
really [ __ ] with that man
well because is it Game of Thrones his
HBO yeah it's coming to a close right
yes okay well well they're Season 8
starting in a week I'm saying but this
is it they need to keep the rhetoric for
HBO going Premium Kate I feel like
people this is a bad this is a bad light
not for them it's not people will still
want to talk people will still watch it
still talk about it still keep going to
it Netflix this would be a bad move
why because Netflix has so much content
that's all out there this would be so
much negative attention for them
that they would have to do it was kind
of like what happened with taking down
the rating system and then and they and
people said it was cuz Schumer special
got all this weird backlash and then
they denied it and they had to deal with
it and then they got annoyed so they
took away the rating system yes right
Netflix wants to put stuff out and not
worry about it they want to go here this
one it's good right huntin this would be
a shitstorm for Netflix but it's a good
shitstorm for HBO it's just way more
[ __ ] attention tons of [ __ ]
attention what else we got oh another
thing yesterday it came out that the
Jackson estate is actually making their
own 30-minute documentary with Michael
Jackson's nephew and the niece who
actually dated the dancer for living
right that's right they dated who he's
dated wait Michael Jackson set up his
niece with rape Wade Robson they dated
for about seven years she comes out
saying that he's a piece of [ __ ] he's
opportunistic he's cheat on me he would
always put himself in situations way
more [ __ ] yeah Wow there she is right
there
see what do you guys think what do you
guys he did probably huh but who but
maybe not I don't know man I don't know
hard see but his documentary did it no
justice cuz I feel like it had me more
mad the whole does that hurt he's alive
his left you right yes my Chin's gotta
do some IT work before we these damn
sites what'd he say he's saying that he
was in a relationship with my uncle
that's better they were in love and that
they were having a relationship if he
will he's saying that my own team beat
these nuts in a row which is just
talking about press together it would
discount or discredit the things that
he's trying to claim and I I find it
fascinating that he thinks it's he's
able to just erase 10 years of his life
yeah yeah it's a trip it's a trip
because it's a tripping as a part of me
he's like hey man
the guy's a [ __ ] sicko Weerd I
thought he was a sicko back then for
laying in bed with kids that bothered
the [ __ ] out of me wait do you have kids
you're really laying in bed laying in
bed with Kerry Wood you let your child
lay in a man's bed
not killing that's I'm saying so that's
my point is like these parents are turds
I don't give a [ __ ] how famous the guy
is you're not my kids not laying in your
bed dude that's [ __ ] weird
that's [ __ ] my I don't know I wish we
have a vision of it Jennifer Lawrence if
a famous hot woman was like I want your
son to sleep in bed with me even then
you'd be like holds my son v60 I'm like
for sure [ __ ] no we're not sixteen if
he's what would a nine summer six yeah
you'd be like no dude you'd be like I'll
come in bed with you no but no my nine
year old can't be in bed with you as I'm
saying it doesn't matter the gender all
right what if she gets in anyway he did
make great music so on a school district
in Indiana started using the untouched
foods that they had left over for lunch
packing them and sending kids off home
with them yeah so just to ensure that
those kids would have meals after this
that is so cool I hate eating the meals
at the in the school band take him home
but I guess you have no food just
[ __ ] yeah these people need that [ __ ]
it just goes to waste I was thinking
about that the other day what did you do
that like it you know it was like I was
there late at night there's all this
food I'm like you guys do with all this
throw it away you have to throw it away
they legally have to throw it away them
bums probably just me well the reason
why they can't give it away is because
at one point companies did try to give
away their leftover foods and people
would sue them saying oh your food got
me sick
and that's why now they have to throw it
away what a [ __ ] dog [ __ ] country what
an insanely stupid thing to happen in
this country you would sue although you
don't Lisa gives you free food because
they should sign a disclaimer that says
it's free it may not be good anymore but
it's not but it's free it's not gonna
kill you it's free oh I mean [ __ ] it but
I but I always thought about that why
don't they give it at the homeless but
they legally can't the store will get in
trouble with the state that's [ __ ] up
but that's the same way I feel about why
don't just let homeless guys sleep
inside of their well but they don't pay
right they don't they don't pay they
don't pay no tax anything yeah it's a
big home that no one's in you can't my
days a week you can't do that I know but
that's my problem can't have them
staying in there I know but the whole
rhetoric of the churches like help the
fellow man and take a nap or you're not
here yeah not that sick and poor though
you know so what is it
no that's a cool move for that for the
school they should all do that Jim you
know how much stuff I used to steal from
the cafeteria when I was called me I was
in the thief dude dude I think I ever
pay you strawberry milks all the time
doggie he was a thief and then what ever
do is my mom would give me like a couple
bucks like for lunch you know like two
bucks maybe and I would save it all week
and I would steal either from the pool
from the cafeteria or from friends yes
and I would have that money at the end
of the week then to buy [ __ ] dude it was
real cards wow that [ __ ] dude yeah yeah
and we would go to the candy store and
we would buy we would buy a root beer
who is at amw root beer and they came in
40 ounce bottles so it looked like 40s
and we'd ask her brown bags and we walk
around bagging a dude so do you guys
know the song old town road
I don't but I see heard about this guy
and I hate his [ __ ] name no dude
you're not nuts you can't use that name
I don't like that I'm not a fancy
country singer no so this guy made a
song a trap song a trap country song and
he posted it it went viral on this app
called tick tock which is basically
today's like vine like Instagram like
put into one it's a hit within the
younger generation so this song the song
went viral yeah
song went viral song went viral it
actually gone to the billboards chart
for hottest country song we took it down
saying that it wasn't country enough and
so lamaze x reach out to Billy Ray Cyrus
to make to get him on the track to make
a country enough he did the remix and
now the song is trending on countries no
you know what they said it wasn't
country enough because he was a black
guy so obvious in the studio
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it's not bad I know what's gonna be
at Trump's neck and next inauguration
feeling Ray Cyrus and little nods x2 I'm
not mad the song though no dude it's not
it's not bad it's not bad but it catchy
it's catchy
it's catchy it's hard to hear someone
brag about their guitar though Iran and
my private beef with country dude why
it's all the same you don't like country
me is like all the same I like country
it's all the same you why cuz they're
all white people
it just sounds the same it's all some
sort of spot means again rap like his
mumble rap right now you belong I don't
like I don't want that his music mumble
rap that's what's hot right now yeah
it's hot but that'll die this has been
around for way long it'll last forever I
don't know if little nas x2 mera no
country do you think yeah and the
Country Music Awards I popped it on for
a second you know like like Bret young
and don't know what that is Florida
Georgia line oh maybe one of the worst
bands of all time
hello Florida Georgia line they have
some hits which one see that dude I
would know it Jim you know that is what
is it I just don't know the name that's
songs give me that give me the tune
who's your favorite favorite country
yeah doesn't exist you don't like
country
I don't like country you don't like Luke
Bryan or all right I like you know what
I like I like I like what country used
to be like folk though we've been okay
but let me see this little nas ex yeah I
don't like his name I saw that it
bothered me the nas is weird yeah man
you're not you can't do that no I don't
like that that happens nowadays I think
that's [ __ ] up and they think it's
funny and he's disrespectful to the
older generation
rappers but I think when I was like dude
don't steal my [ __ ] name no I'm still
at gnosis all the Mafia's still alive he
is still alive
you know what disappointed me did I tell
you about this this bothered me for my
birthday when I saw NAS in Vegas four
years ago and we got VIP and all this
dope ass [ __ ] I'm like backstage he's
reading his lyrics off of a teleprompter
because he was doing Illmatic you know
the film addict probably best out of all
time yes and and and he was reading off
to help prompter and I so hurt oh my god
like the hip-hop head and it was like
but no no I know these songs he's so old
though he needs just a reaction I think
maybe he might have been in Vegas out
but still maybe feels very [ __ ] I guess
you're going to see your favorite
comedian you saw Dave Chappelle reading
off a teleprompter toughen links and the
people with me were like who cares and I
was like how do you I care I care how do
you even read that fast though that's
kind of impressive yeah nobody needed as
a touch point but if I was so [ __ ]
weird I was like that's not know she
goes yeah let's do this
all Schwarzenegger in the new Terminator
signal in Des Moines dude no no I'm out
man I haven't seen a terminus since
Terminator 3 no I'm going to wear an
Invictus watch the size of a basketball
come on do it come on really now are
these watches that are the separate
let's show wait saucers that oh my god
slender how much holy [ __ ] you look in
here like him she still looks good dude
she still looks real good for a try okay
yeah Theo von
uh I think you have to ill looks good
for his age to wait other character so
when is this [ __ ] come out 2019 November
oh this is hard path I just can't get
into who the [ __ ] is that
I don't know these pictures from the
movie there's just people in the film
the first shots that are available scant
[ __ ] with it man I grew up on part 1
part 2 part want you were the best it's
so hard for me to do that now that these
these action stars are coming like the
Jason Momoa well but also the rock go do
terminator again don't do yeah I don't
need you to recruit right right some new
right a new predator and
they can't don't do predator I can't
there's another movie there's a movie
coming out called the little the little
like Regina King right yeah but it's
freaking again and again and we've done
this movie a thousand times or instead
of think like a woman think like a man
but we've done these things already but
this one's even more worse because this
concept itself of like you know it's big
where does he become you know and I mean
but 13 going on 30
it's all these movies not writers have
to come with new [ __ ] and they are they
fine they don't want to risk it oh dude
I want to risk it anyway then this movie
is it yet we're gonna say no speaking
about that but first before I get to
that real quick jesse smaller is
supposed to be returning to the set of
empire can't wait can't wait such a fan
such a fan I'm a fan of his it is such a
big fan and a good person good guy good
how alive and real he's real
returning to Empire for Season six you
know why they did this right because
they want to feel good about themselves
cuz [ __ ] Fox or whoever wants to be
like we're larger than these issues
because we still support him well sorta
love my he still uh he's still a gay
black eye so that's done [ __ ] someone be
like like [ __ ] Joe bomber call it was
like my Nate a fox he got decimated for
a [ __ ] n-double-a-cp award and didn't
show up they nominated this guy and
Chris Rock roasted yeah I know he should
have stoled not you should have roasted
him even harder I agree n-double-a-cp
award I tweeted it I said and the award
for my bad goes to jussie Smollett they
let this guy don't you float don't you
think the black community is like
whatever no I think a lot of them [ __ ]
think this is wack I think you'd I think
they think so I think it's wack I then
stop watching power or where the [ __ ]
it's called Empire Empire that stop
watching same that's so funny stop
watching power stuff watch a stop
watching kid and play stop watching
family matter
stop doing it just the Jeffersons is not
your show Fresh Prince the biller
wait but the hope he's returning and see
I thought they killed him on the show I
think it was like the new one he's a
ghost doesn't ambiguous ending but so
it's cuz that girl taraji P Henson was
on the view yeah as she was saying like
it I heard that he's coming back we
haven't heard anything else so it could
be a thing where they're still deciding
damn dude you know like I don't think he
I don't think you should never get work
again I'm 99 that's but I think this is
I think this is a [ __ ] move on their
part they should have been like look man
we separate times you because you didn't
do the right thing and apparently they
said they hate they couldn't say I'm
working with a guy that's why they
wanted a mop that she oh yeah I also
said Terrence Howard wonderful yeah I
don't he was pissed off they should they
should let him fight turns Howard for
his job cool is you go toe to toe
descent on that show too then a Howard
do same show this is black billions yeah
I have no idea I have no idea
we'll see already the movie that has
never been written before mmm this guy
Lee Daniels also the creator of Empire
yeah he says he's gonna make the first
super deal this a superhero movie yeah
great
yeah it's called Superman or it's called
Aquaman so this guy is the same guy put
out the video defending Jesse small yeah
this is the guy who [ __ ] over Dame
Dash and it paying the money what do you
what did he defend Josie smell how did
he defend him she's doing that post that
videos like I want you to stab me some
and I you and this like he's he was
defending them got ain't no it almost
felt like he was part of it in a way
like he knew about inside that to it
yeah I'm so original you're writing the
first gay superhero Wow you'll know this
because this guy that's supposed to play
the superheroes give me Silver Surfer
from the moment I saw him on that
[ __ ] board you've seen this guy he
went viral before you'll know what you
see this play this first okay
do y'all remember maybe 10 12 years ago
I said my dream I don't trust him why I
don't at all make a gay superhero is he
gay yes yes it's about to happen
super [ __ ] is here Oh Delia angles
mm-hmm and we are we are he's not
sucking off him at all that's he's
definitely not eating his [ __ ] at all
nope get ready cuz I'm about to give
y'all combo oh my [ __ ] god
please remember this guy I don't yes all
right way back this one bleach media
bleach media made me money no put my
head on this guy body
let me tell you something
shaking it combo let me tell you
something so athletic because various
like and not racist at all
no you know when you see a bio he's a I
don't know that's why they talk athletic
let's say this so I think gay super a
movie is gonna dance on the line of do a
super Robin those are so easy well
they're all gay I mean they're all that
well no yeah Batman thank a Batman might
be the only one is not gay Robin this
Superman was gay agree Clark Kent death
worked at a newspaper changed in a phone
booth
yeah faster than a speeding bullet
pachow boob a Bing boom boom mmm also
how come we never saw him [ __ ] Lois Lane
ever no sader
say saving her be delayed more if you
notice a more dude thing that he always
saved more toys dude he never wanted to
pop Lois and she always want to get
slammed and she was like what the [ __ ]
is the deal the ghillies flies off yeah
trying to [ __ ] you fly she's like I love
you thank you for saving me let me suck
your comfort where does he go the gay
superhero movies Austin Robin but it's
just gonna be like it's gonna be all too
much no that's the promise to me too
much and they're gonna shove it down
society's throat like Java like it it's
gonna be cool yeah yeah why but why see
this is my problem with this the an
actor could be gay who plays a superhero
right but why does his sexuality need to
be defined in the movie like that what I
don't have anything with Moya
why why did why can't why can't Deadpool
beep into dudes who gives a [ __ ] my
Deadpool isn't by yeah he's mine
he does have a boyfriend in the comment
he does what he does he does he knows
that's true but you know what they don't
harp on it in the series cuz it's not
the music but also no one gives a [ __ ]
but this is my point I don't this
doesn't need to be like the sexuality
doesn't need to be the thing that the
movie focus yeah I don't even see him
save adieu didn't suck him off also why
would a queer man be gay dude out of all
the characters he is gay he's gay lives
with the fish he swims swim
yeah he swims a lot yeah but this guy's
flipping and public bathrooms with
submission tape crazy alright what else
you got I mean that's just give us one
more chin come on all right this is
pretty big chris darden the guy from the
oj simpson saga mm-hmm the lawyer he's
actually gonna take the defense side of
that a guy that killed allegedly killed
know he doesn't kill what wait wait oh
they have video hell yeah and this
dumbass is defending him
what's it that's all are wondering why
like he's doing it they think it's cuz
he's not getting attention it's money
money too gotta be mean like
african-american loser Nipsey Hussle
would be is it he was such an advocate
for african-americans losing is such a
big loss you're saying cause lack [ __ ]
century and another black lord if he was
white be like yeah yeah but his defense
is probably gonna be I wonder what is
the assumed his defense is gonna be
something along lines of like Chris guy
was either framed or he's out of his
mind or it was a gang push hit that he
didn't so it's gonna be more about the
motive of this man to kill that doesn't
matter I know but I know I know I know
I'm just saying cuz you're playing he's
gonna do so he won opposite team yeah
he's gonna find a sneaky way to make it
look like this guy's is was forced to
kill nipsey by a gang or so you know I
mean like that Dave's like oh well I
wouldn't be surprised if he gets some
assassination I thought the streets were
gonna kill him all that [ __ ] on Twitter
who - I thought they'd do that in a game
did you see the games
yeah I grabbed everyone one dude the
game was like the game was like let the
streets get him let the streets get him
and honestly I thought for sure the
streets were gonna get him by then one
the streets to get him know I pull it
it's over yourself to do easy now he's
[ __ ] well dude well not when
no he won't rot when he gets there
they're gonna kill him I mean they're
gonna they're gonna they're gonna
[ __ ] kill his ass he's not necessary
because did you see all hear what
happened to whitey bulger in prison huh
oh well because he'd like killed a lot
of the other but whatever cartel guys
yeah well the other cartel guys got
ahold of him beat him with lots
scentless senseless just got him it and
just beat him blocks in a pillowcase
beat him to death wolf dude I mean as
soon as they get home like what they do
in there I mean cuz you saw the
Instagram video that was put up the game
a lot of you put it up every gang in LA
March the other day down to nipsey's
spot to celebrate as you're talking
literal Crips and bloods walking
side-by-side not celebrate but yeah no
no they were just walking in silence
side by side smoking blunts Sam what's
up like staying cool he put it on his it
was on his or II it might have been on
his story
it was destroy you as he was driving
yeah you see the one with the night that
happened
well Google hey Google Google la gangs
go to nipsey's spot I mean if [ __ ]
drones get at the local news put it on
the news it was such a big deal it was
like such a huge deal that they were
like because Crenshaw was shut down for
the day and these gangs walked
hand-in-hand to nipsey's store look at
that largest gang peace rally it was
[ __ ] it to go down see if there's
photos at the walk dude it was crazy to
watch people were stripped it ripped no
it's all it was over it was I was on the
internet somewhere but but anything
about that kodak black dont after his
[ __ ] feel that listen this morning i
listened this morning to him kind of
defending what what he said trying to
like give a defense to what he was
saying soon you just he was making a bad
joke he thought he was being just a
whack job he's a dumbass yeah he's done
that also by the way you know that body
and those face death to bring up a photo
of just kodak black and i cuz I was
gonna tweet this the other dinner scene
his body just just just his face just
his face let's put an image may be the
ugliest [ __ ] feather I've ever seen
in my life ever this kid is so goofy
looking Oh terrible lookin whoa what a
[ __ ] who is [ __ ] this guy girls if
you're your [ __ ] in the sky are you
alright yeah oh look alive ladies look
at that picture right down there in the
red go go to the yeah that one
that guy so once I dog yeah it's on
yeah yak-yak-yak sure little prize all
right dude [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that guy [ __ ]
that guy for going after a dead guy's
wife that's so [ __ ] up
piece of [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] dude anyway
they just Oh guess Rick use your own
Rookie of the Year this was Rookie of
the Year dude I'm really proud you like
to go Chicago kid the rook Rookie of the
Year yeah finally by lovin funky but
love it yeah bro mom garnered that was
his name Clooney's dates throw out these
[ __ ] dates you hot sexy [ __ ] dude
where are you gonna be though dude I'm
doing some Rogen [ __ ] I'm not I'm not
gonna go back on the road on my own for
a little while Joe and I are gonna play
arenas so you're Joe doing you 420 in
San Diego 20 and Sandy one actually gets
left there that's it yeah it's barely
that of I think 12,000 this weekend I'll
be in Atlanta and I'm going to UFC to
watch Joe do his thang that you've been
to UFC but yeah okay owner Chicago to
watch UFC in June again with him doing
Chicago to an arena they're so good look
at Rogen's website I'll be there and
then you do that thing on tour I'm going
I'm getting my dates later for you yeah
I'm chilling right now for you man you
have to serve your beasts Thank You dog
I'm in Phoenix end of the month 26 and
27th were you at I'm at the stand-up
live there downtown stand-up live I
think so yeah you're gonna love it
I've been there before two shows Friday
two shows Saturday and I'm in Tampa May
10th through the 11th temp of improv yet
and then just announced Cleveland I'm in
Cleveland May 30th through June 1st get
your tickets now Steve at kake.com
my man go get that [ __ ] you're feeling
thank you bro the fighter now red rocket
don't forget fighter in the red rocket
don't forget us is the fighter in the
rocket wrap